wir machen unser eigenes geht dass sie
perfekt jeder mal geld zwei kleinganoven
rang und athris versuchen ein krummes
ding zu drehen kommen dabei aber in
kontakt mit größerer kriminellen welt
aus allen himmelsrichtungen dass einige
dieser stadt gelassen 48 stunden nicht
mein leben sein werden also nicht
geplant der schlüssel um den sich alles
dreht der zu einem wertfach führt am
berliner hauptbahnhof in dem eine menge
geld liegt das geld hier werden sich die
das geht hier zu lassen nein das geld
ist woanders woanders gar nicht das geld
hingelegt
dass diese schlüsse unter umständen
verloren geht die nur durch eine
erhebliche menge von schmutz oder etwas
drastischer substanzen behoben werden
kann
die beiden hauptdarsteller sind jung
stars des deutschen kinos markus
schneider und jannis niewöhner mein
freund frank über verschuldet bei dem
sieben hektar
das war nicht komisch zu sterben
der eigentliche star von asphalt kurios
ist aber glaube ich der darsteller eines
der orientalischen paten nämlich ramadan
wenn sie nicht schlafen jetzt gehst du
brauchst du wiederkommst die der ramadan
verleiht dem film gorillas das klima
eines echten parken fehlens eines eines
kriminal epos gemacht was wird euch fast
alle kennen das koki wie man in berlin
sagt als einen ort an dem sich
drogenkuriere kleinkriminelle und
touristen gute nach zahlen um in dieser
gegend spielt auch ein wesentlicher teil
von asphalt corinna so weiter machst du
dann das glück glaubst dann passiert
etwas völlig unerwartetes um die sache
dreht sich wieder ganz offensichtlich
sollen wir dieses gefährliche oder
zumindest ein bisschen in berlin mit
ethnischen ecken und kanten in asturias
auch noch einmal sehen
[Musik]
es geht drunter und drüber als auch
humor funktioniert für meine begriffe
nicht im grunde ist das kein film den
man empfehlen würde
allerdings finde ich das auf einer
anderen ebene sehr interessant ist denn
er erzählt sehr deutlich der form dass
das deutsche kino die schwierigkeiten
hat interessante geschichten zu finden
und sich deswegen immer wieder auf
milieus stürzt von denen man erwartet
dass dort einfach ganz simpel gesagt
noch etwas los ist und das ist in dem
fall geben dass türkisch orientierende
berlin das gebot meine liebe wer
allerdings einen gut erzählten
interessante ironischen gangsterfilm
erwartet wird wohl enttäuscht werden
manchmal muss man genau das machen
sondern am samstag durch